the Captain America and Black Panther
game is gonna be insane here's why so
the first ever Disney and Marvel game
showcase is in the books arguably the
biggest reveal is this Untitled Captain
America and Black Panther game set
during World War II but that's not
necessarily the most exciting part the
game is being developed by Sky dance New
Media whose president is Amy Henning Amy
is most notably known for the immensely
underrated Legacy Kane series and being
the creative director of three small
games you may have heard about now
there's a shroud of mystery around why
she left naughty dog in 2014 but that's
not all everything she did on Uncharted
4 was scrapped the legendary voice of
Nathan Drake Nola North went on to say
it was about seven months of work given
uncharted's history of ushering in a new
era of cinematic video games under Amy's
Direction you can only imagine how she's
going to bring that wealth of knowledge
to Captain America and Black Panther I
mean it can't get any more disappointing
than this right
[Music]